hey everyone persia here and animal
crossing new horizons has a bunch of
summer updates in store for us and part
one is already
out one thing with the new update
is golovar r
a new special character that's joining
the roster that you can find
sprawled out on your beach just like the
normal gulliver
and the biggest difference between
gulliver and gullivar
is that he's a pirate so all of the
items that you can get from him
are pirate themed and in today's video
we are going to show off
all 27 items that you can get
from gulliver's all right i got all the
items out of the way because we need to
take a moment to truly appreciate
the walls and the flooring so we have
the pirate wall and the pirate flooring
which has all the loot on the floor all
the coins
my favorite part is obviously the sound
then of course when you walk off of the
coins you hear
nothing but the deck okay so
here are the furniture items not
including the rug but just the items
that you can actually place
we have a sideways pirate barrel we have
a standing pirate barrel and you can put
items on top of the barrel
we also have the pirate ship helm
which you can interact with of the
pirate treasure chest and then of course
the cannon
i really love the rug it's like a
treasure map it's
pretty good in size it has the
torn edges and corners and definitely
fits the theme
and there's the furniture items so let's
go ahead and check out
the clothing from the gulliver set
and here are all the clothing items you
can get from the gulliver set down to
the beard
and the eye patch we have two separate
hats we have a crown
and the captain's hat which i am decked
out right now
in the robe got the boots on so we have
three different types of dresses
we have a black version a red version
and the blue version then we also have
the pirate
outfit in the same three colors black
version
red version and blue version
and then we also have the pirate pants
which are gonna go with the sea
captain's coat which also comes in the
same
three colors and then let's go ahead and
see the
treasure crown on and he quits yes very
nice
and then of course the pirate boots i do
have them on right now
um but yeah there's a close-up half has
little skulls on the side
adorable and then the three pirates
bandanas also which
this looks so great together but
obviously
these three colors as well and pirate
golivar
works a little bit differently than
regular gulliver you're not going to be
running around the beach
digging up clams on accident
looking for communicator parts you're
actually going to be
using the new summer update of swimming
to dive into the water
find the communicator itself and then
deliver it back to gullivar
it's pretty interesting that the phone
still works after digging it out from
deep sea diving but hey he's the
professional pirate he has the tech
so once you return the phone to him the
next day
you will get an item and it works just
like
gulliver and if you actually hang on to
the communicator
the following day it will turn into five
communicator parts
if you were wondering about that and if
you're trying to make the robot hero
and for all of you who have tuned in
we're gonna be giving away
this entire set to one lucky person who
comments below
just tell us which item that you love
the most from the set
in a comment below and you could win and
make sure you're keeping an eye on the
comment section because i will be
replying to one of you
to get your information so i can deliver
the set to you
so comment down below your favorite item
you could win the set hope you enjoyed
the video
and keep your eyes peeled for more
animal crossing new horizons content on
gamespot see you later
you